so we already talked about the visibly
sweaty and orange Donald Trump bragging
to a Colorado Springs crowd about his
followers essentially being cultists I
want to take a few minutes now to
mention more generally that at that same
rally in Colorado Springs and at the
following one that he did in Las Vegas
Nevada
Donald Trump looked and sounded more
unwell than we've seen in a really long
time and the things he was saying were
concerning the way he looked was
concerning and the way he sounded was
concerning and people are noticing the
International Business Times reported
Trump reportedly looks bad at Vegas
rally POTUS suffering from mental
physical decline a number of other
articles asked essentially the same
questions let's look at some examples
from two events again it's the Colorado
Springs rally and then a Las Vegas rally
Trump again visibly sweaty very red
upper Trump in Colorado Springs downer
Trump in Las Vegas maybe Trump arriving
sort of late East Coast time for the
Colorado Springs rally maybe needed a
little something to get him going for
that one wouldn't be surprising if he
was giving himself a boost with
something check out Trump unable to read
his teleprompter in the context that the
speech is written slurring about the
Rocky Mountains making no syntactical
sense here the majestic peaks of the
Rocky Mountains with thousands of
terrific hard-working great American
patriots Trump then started wildly
reading totally out of context numbers
with no reasonable inflection where you
can even understand what on earth this
guy is talking about seventy percent
next one is 18 percent next one is seven
four three three three two one one
one truck did well in the debate see
their fake news then Trump's luring and
attacking someone not exactly sure who
this is now I feel good now I feel
she's a third-rate journalist let's go
we're standing up in defense of our
Constitution and then Trump started
mixing up conflicting conspiracy
theories which was really weird try to
understand this and look at how he takes
like two or three words from different
conspiracy theories and you know we're
working with the cloud we're working
with these people that want to take you
out they want to change the results they
got caught spying let's sit like this
right they got caught spying on our
election figures hey fakers take your
cameras for a change and show them the
room and shown behind the cloud spying
fake news election like it's completely
dissembling in front of our very eyes
then he starts talking about mayor Pete
and I guess now he's referring to mayor
Pete as Buddha touch Buddha touch listen
to this a pretty woman Buddha touch
little Buddha touch I said I've had you
up to here they had little footages
leading Donald Trump in Texas these
people but very close but he said it's
too close to call this is a poll where
Buddha dead so friend of mine from Texas
a big powerful strong guy real touch
he's got the cowboy hat I'd loved the
way that I would have to pull by air so
boy
I wouldn't need hairspray I'd love those
Texas SATs I don't know if we get away
with it or Washington that's why all
they bro but I love her then Trump
really struggling to say the word
statistics telling you within a very
short period of time you're gonna see
some statistics coming out on what
statistics I got to do it right
otherwise so say what's wrong I like
that status thix so this is already bad
enough right this is Colorado Springs
but then we go to Las Vegas and things
get even worse Trump trying to talk
about some health care plan he was
supposedly going to do already but then
it never happened and he sounds like a
used car salesman notice that Trump in
Vegas this is now downer Trump Trump in
Colorado Springs was upper Trump red
talking quickly this is now downer Trump
talking about we're gonna give you brand
new pre-existing now you might be saying
there's got to be some other word
missing there yeah but Trump's talking
about brand new pre-existing Obamacare
but we're gonna terminate it we're gonna
give you your pre-existing 100 otherwise
I won't do it we're going to give you
brand new pre-existing and we're gonna
have a great health care that's much
less expensive then Trump mocks Joe
Biden for his stutter
that's a disability it's like mocking
someone for having diabetes and that's
what happens when you can't get the
words out no it does that's what happens
right when you can't get the words out
you get angry you get angry because you
can't get the words that might happen to
me someday can you imagine that that
happened to me man would I be a bad guy
and then this is the height of
megalomania Trump claims and maybe
believes that if a plane crashed with
700 people on it media wouldn't cover it
but instead they would talk about Donald
Trump
you know cable was supposed to be
absolutely
and how they're doing the highest
numbers they've ever done if an airplane
goes down with 700 people they don't
cover it if it's not truck related they
don't company it's got to be tough or
tough related so the plane goes down and
it's total devastation if the ship goes
down if the Titanic the Titanic
equivalent went down they wouldn't cover
it unless I was on the sucker and then
of course the capstone the slurring
begins to take place in Vegas remember
Trump was upper Trump in Colorado
Springs Trump downer Trump in Vegas and
downer Trump often does the slurring
introduce President Alfred a moment but
see nobody knows because you're all too
young nobody knows who Alfred it's bad
magazine it's very bad it's very bad and
people around Donald Trump are
continuing to privately sound the alarm
and at this rate if this continues the
debates are going to be something else
it will be like nothing we have ever
seen before no matter who the Democratic
nominee eventually is I I presume that
upper Trump would be better for the
debates than downer Trump and so we
would expect more the Trump that was in
Colorado Springs than the Trump that was
in Las Vegas Nevada
let me know what you think I don't know
what to make of it at this point one of
our sponsors today is a game called
lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive
you make election promises to your
constituents it's up to you whether you
keep those promises when you're in
office all of the laws you pass affect
your country's happiness and safety
healthcare environment you can abolish
laws that are already in place you can
ratify the Constitution you decide if
you want the government to be a healthy
democracy or authoritarian tyranny you
can be
corrupt and take bribes political
assassinations are part of the game it's
nuts actually it's a really good time it
doesn't get old because you'll never
play it the same way twice this is not
some cheesy free-to-play game it's very
clear that a lot of time went into the
development it has very positive reviews
on Steam and in the App Store's four and
a half stars or higher on all platforms
go to david pakman.com slash game which
is where you can watch the trailer
download the game for Steam iOS and
Android that's david pakman.com slash
game